if I gave up producing content at the
same time that most of you give up all
the greatest things that have happened
to me professionally
would not be happening the Monday rant
video was reverse engineered take a step
back and think about how awesome it
actually is I just knew that people
would want to watch it I like and that's
what I also think is gonna happen here
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk director of
operations here at Wine Library and Wine
Library calm and I am very proud to
launch what we think is the first video
light blog if you want this if you want
bling bling if you want to buy the Jets
if you want to do [ __ ] work that's how
you get it I know that I'm built to win
when it comes to business I always win
I'm gonna win snapchat is a
communication funnel that for those nine
seconds while you're holding it you
actually have to pay attention I feel
like I've got a team now in place to
actually do this more often so here we
go I fully fully 100 thousand percent
with no hedge do not believe that you
can teach entrepreneurship right so
that's awkward
you could ended up being a bus a tree I
just don't get the mentality of being
head down sad I'm not some great
philosopher this is simple [ __ ] one at
that I'm scared that you don't realize
that you're entering the greatest five
year window of your life I just don't
understand why people relegate into
losing mentality and just thinking they
can there's plenty of time get [ __ ] done
you're gonna die yeah that's inspiration
do something about it
do something about it so please my
friends understand that you've got to
keep creating literally one piece of
content can change your game can change
your outcome if I if I gave up when most
of you usually give up then I too would
not have any of the business success
that you guys all see now keep creating